hey guys it's Pete peppers from candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
level 72 walkthrough tutorial and I'm
gonna play pretty faster these first
couple things because this is a long
level and the tips for this are in our
guide already and they're pretty pretty
good so make sure you read those if
you're having trouble need to move to
these rooms fast so I gotta say that the
movie possibly came
so only activate the fish he'll go right
after that striped Amy and that'll never
see their here we're trying to move down
so we can use this striped to free the
color color bomb there
all right we'll go ahead and make
another color bomb while we plead out
one go ahead and do that that'll clear
out that entire column move the bear all
the way over all right so some of them
said this is where it gets difficult and
something that's interesting here so we
have a setup that will if we can get a
yellow to explode this little chute down
and get off both of the fish at the same
time before we do anything like that we
want to bring the bear onto the board
and if you bring the bear out then the
fish will always kind of go in front of
it and move it along if you can't see it
then they won't do that so it's
something to keep my it's actually more
important in the next room but it's
important to keep in mind throughout
because if you get like a nice cascade
going or something like that the fish
will actually go up here they'll go out
to the blockers first anyways but in the
next room I've run into that a couple
times where all I needed was you know
some fish to move that up on the board
and because it wasn't blocked it with I
mean because it wasn't on the screen the
fish to be help at all so definitely
keep that wrong
so we just want to make we don't have
any matches out here you want to check
that first but we you know we don't have
any so what we really want to do now is
make more specials and once these
blockers are gone the fish will help us
both
you know what we'd like to do is get rid
of those while setting some of them up
and then fish fish plus stripe to be
really important if we can make those
later color bombs are pretty much always
useful because you can take out one
whole color so we got one two three four
veins we have just one yellow so that's
like there's only three orange so we'll
go with the green get it out of the way
all right so now we can
no and go ahead and do this cuz that's
gonna hit the block down a little bit
now all the fish that we use will help
us out we really need to make some more
fish and some more stripes and try to
get them together and get out of this
room
at this point we want vertical fishing
more but we'll take whatever you can get
because if we fire those off you know
they'll still move it up one notch
all right so at this point if we can
make a fish if you can match with this
it'll clear out that entire column so
that is the goal
all right so let's that's not too bad in
that room and all the Pens you sort of
have to get through all three of these
last ones pretty fast so it can be a
little bit frustrating because you do
get in one and then you get stuck in
another one but but that's the nature of
this type of level so just try to keep
your frustration under control if you
can
so we want to pop a couple bottles so we
can see the bear and then we can do the
same thing we did in the last one
better get these cakes out of the way so
that's never bad to do that you just
want look around first to make sure that
there's nothing else going on that
you're gonna miss out we're gonna pop in
a bottle or getting rid of the licorice
I'm gonna go ahead and fire this off so
I can see the bear
all right so he's out there we need to
pop the rest of the bottles and get
those soda level up I know I had to get
out so that we can create a nice
vertical striped antipasto fish
so there's a fish rid of the rest of the
cakes because they will you know
obviously go after those first and that
won't help us at all so
I miss the color and candy there cuz I
went too fast that's a little bit of a
mistake but hopefully it won't come back
to harness
yeah
this wouldn't be bad to mix those
together better than making a horizontal
stripe it'll take out a few of those or
two of them next you say
okay here we go
all right so we have nine moves left
it's not not fantastic but we'll see
what happens here got a pop a few
bottles and then get moving up top
so these holes in the board here make
this pretty tough this is going to help
out a lot when we pop a bottle before we
do that
not really
I'm not really sure what's gonna happen
here when I look over the board I don't
see anything better to do though it will
pop all the bottles and fill up the soda
it will get at least a few of these out
of here but I don't know how it's gonna
end up but as I was like I said as I
look over the board I can't pop any
bottles first and like we could pop
three bottles before we did this that
would be good but there's no way to do
that right now so I'm just gonna go
ahead and I mean I don't even think
about the fact that I might change those
so that might get us right up to where
we need to be anyway so all right that's
it that's how you do it like I said we
have tips for each of the first levels
and it's important to get there as fast
as you possibly can and then you just
have to plan a lot of these levels that
really get people trouble or ones where
you know there's no the because of the
layout and this boards hard especially
to because it's a lot of moves and it
takes a lot of time and you can get
frustrated and it feels like you can't
do it so you just want to quit but you
know make sure you really take your time
because there's no you're not gonna just
win it by blowing stuff up and get lucky
that doesn't you know they're not it's
not a cascade have you bored like that
it's a it's technical one that you have
to move those bears up the side so just
follow what what I did there keep it in
mind and you'll get it eventually so I
hope this helps make sure you share the
video like it subscribe to our channel
help support us for going the extra mile
and making these kinds videos when we
make more sense thanks